yeah yeah what's wrong with the word
even the fake movie in the fake grand
theft auto world waste precious movie
seconds on production logos also the
movies main title totally rips off the
used gears and bolts to make letters
thing from Robin Williams film robots
futuristic blimp travel requires two
blimps this flying bike has no rider
which makes about as much sense as a
flying bike scratches all over the
fucking film lousy film print or lousy
projectionist either way not my problem
I think new it England manufactures
sarcasm by the way what's that this
stamp is a dick to cock munchers why
does he have to use a clipboard I mean
this is a world with unmanned flying
bicycles
he can't digitize his notes I'll admit
Maureen is a hottie but keeping pictures
like this on your work clipboard is one
of the best ways I can think of to get
fired clocking out sequence obviously
just a robot a sized version of the
Flintstones
this guy's butt cheeks also in the
future they apparently use those ticker
tape machines that are obsolete even by
today's standards in Great Britain it
isn't important what the name of the pub
is you just need to know that it's a pub
logical gay robot does not realize his
own gayness is probably skewing the
gaydar results the loneliest robot in
Great Britain keeps his TV on all day
playing static this robot is a dick to
electric bills discount Atari 2600 I've
never been a part of a three-person
handjob but I have to believe neither
the male's really gets the attention he
deserves also robots have pants and hair
curlers and penis the scene is too
brutal so we'll only show the shadow
cliche even in the movie inside Grand
Theft Auto the hero ends up killing the
hooker code 44 but I thought matters
concerning a robot hurting a human was
the first law of robotics we give a lot
of de movie gunslingers for being
horrible shots but cartoon robots even
though they hit him a couple of times
those guys should have way better aim
how is he hiding there were hundreds of
robots surrounding him a second ago did
they lose sight of him oh no credits I
wanted to know who the chief animator
was yep I just paid 20 bucks for a
10-minute movie
kitten Gordon Dean can't have a rash I
developed it myself
yes siree this is my ticket upstairs who
is that piece of crumpet no for kidding
mrs. Robinson you're trying to seduce me
aren't you my stars my daddy gate door
is off the charts
oh yeah find that we are my dear friend
Peter we just never end each other gonna
be intersexual whole section
intersection I gotta go